hi I'm Timmy the trashcan and I love
trash popcorn boxes and candy wrappers
hmm
they all taste so good instead of
throwing your trash on the floor won't
you please give it to me and thank you
for considering your fellow patrons
sitting here in the backyard in West
Hollywood we are not on the porch I want
to apologize everybody on YouTube that
has spent a lot of money to watch this
show done on a porch it will be done on
a porch again fear not the Ben is here I
just got off tour with Bert just got off
a [ __ ] bus
and then a plane and now I'm back in
West Hollywood and I lost my [ __ ]
phone I just lost my phone there is no
feeling worse than losing your phone it
used to be your wallet because I've lost
both your phone is now your wallet your
I don't care about my while throw my
wallet in a river I don't get what am I
gonna lose business card an executive at
truTV no thanks I'll throw my wallet in
the LA River but my [ __ ] phone is my
lifeline you can do nothing without a
phone and like an idiot we got off the
plane Bert had a car we jumped in the
car went to Bert's house I got an uber
pulls up in a black Jeep Liberty Russian
chick a lot of plastic surgery I even
said to myself I made a mental note
don't leave anything in this [ __ ] car
you will not see it again cause she'll
know how to move it she will know how to
get rid of that [ __ ] whatever I leave
in that [ __ ] car which again all I
have is my phone I even made like a
weird mental
when I saw her and as soon as she said
hello and I could hear the accent was
like Russian or you know maybe Ukrainian
one of the ex-soviet republic didn't
feel particularly comfortable with with
the chance that I would get my property
returned to me I saw the amount of
plastic surgery I'm like she's got a few
different hustles going on and I was one
of those hustles today and I left my
[ __ ] phone in the backseat of this
uber and as soon as I walked in the
house I checked I did I didn't
immediately I didn't make the connection
and then about cuz I look at my phone
you realize you look at your phone every
few minutes so as soon as I set my [ __ ]
down and I got a glass of water I went
[ __ ] wait what where's the phone I
thought my pocket I'm like where is the
phone and there was no phone and I said
okay and I went I tore my room apart and
then immediately panic began to set in
because I'm like [ __ ] I lost this phone
I have people's numbers in there that
are important I have people that I don't
want being called I don't need people
calling the numbers I have in the phone
okay um I call been on my FaceTime on my
Mac and Ben goes hey there's a Sprint
store open you can go there no problem
I'll get your lift Ben used to drive
lifts so he deals with lifts it does not
deal with uber he deals with lifts lifts
is clearly the lesser of the two
services and they employ people who are
both emotionally disturbed you know
mentally deficient these people are I
don't know how anyone who does lift has
a license I don't know how they got a
license when you get in a lift you not
only you
taking your life in your hands I mean
it's crazy it's a real difference it's
not just a [ __ ] hockey joke premise
although there's a lot of people with
those types of jokes I forget maybe it
was ELISA Lim Paris
I think somebody on Twitter was like she
had a great tweet about like you getting
an uber for skating in a lift you know
and you get or maybe she did a video
about and you get in the lift and it's
[ __ ] mayhem so I'm like okay I'm
gonna go now and I don't know how long
it's gonna take cause if I have
insurance you know hopefully I have it I
think I have insurance I didn't have
Find My iPhone I thought I did but if
the phone's off it doesn't matter anyway
my phone was dead so it didn't matter
anyway and I get in the lift with a
MacBook and a guy pulls up all guy it's
a lift so it's a chevy cruze to small
bright red Chevy Cruze if I had a Chevy
Cruze boy I would get it in a color that
blended in you know what I mean like I
would not advertise my Chevy Cruze with
like a candy apple red this is a cruise
it's not a Malibu this is a cruise the
cruise is the smaller car it's like a
two-door it looks like a lot of these
cars now look like somebody [ __ ] a car
it is the the the literal aesthetic of
the car the shape is like it just
plopped onto the street and I get in the
cruise and I have the MacBook because I
said I'm gonna have to call you back to
order another one of these [ __ ] while
I'm in Sprint they get in the Chevy
Cruze with what I imagine is a lunatic
we drive to the nearest Sprint store he
pulls me up to a corner and goes I papa
hi papa
this is you all right pop
this is you well no it wasn't me because
there was no Sprint store and I said I'm
looking for a Sprint store he's like God
no Sprint store Papa I said well well
then I'm gonna stay in the car because I
was going to the Sprint store so as long
as you're treating me you're gonna call
me Papa treat me like your father and
let's find the store he goes this is you
Papa says here Sprint I said I don't see
Sprint because yeah I don't either I
don't need a Papa so I say to him I roll
the window down I said oh guy you know
buddy Sprint store in this area he heard
of one ever seen one the guy goes no
keeps walking I say to the driver I say
what was happening because I don't know
so I'm like maybe like sometimes with a
restaurant it had been closed already
been remodeled or whatever but you had
told me Bennet said I'd spoke to the guy
at the Sprint store so I'm like there is
a store somebody answered the phone so
Ben says the address is 3 whatever I
this guy allows me to call back I call
Ben then says the address this guy goes
all went out of three we're 291 Papa I
said I yeah no good he goes Papa maybe
we should drive around and look for this
print store I said well that would be
lovely it would be very nice if we could
find the thing that I want to go to can
we do that because that is the point of
the service I know it was fun to drive
with you he had Fleetwood Mac on which I
appreciate he did not look like he was a
Fleetwood Mac fan I don't like to make
rush judgements but I did not think he
would be getting into Stevie Nixon I was
I said well that's nice you know um we
we drive up and down the block no Sprint
store we then go we pull in front of
this big parking garage and he goes
maybe the Sprint store is in there
and I go I don't know but I don't think
so I don't see any signs that say sprint
so he goes yeah papa no good I said no
it is not good I go let me just have my
friend Ben change the location on this
he goes buddy this is a pool can't
change location I said it's arid it's
not a pool
it's not a pool because yeah this is a
share he goes you you somebody else is
gonna come in here now and I said well
if somebody else gets in that's fine but
I'm letting you know this right now I
selected the feature where I would just
go to the place if this is not a
situation so he looks at the phone he
goes you're right papa I said okay sure
then we call Ben Ben changes the address
this guy drops from you off cuz I don't
have a phone I'm not walking around La
with a Macbook like a psychopath going
into different businesses going can I
use your Wi-Fi so I can FaceTime my
friend so he can call me a lift because
that's literally what I would have had
to do hey can I get on the Wi-Fi here so
I could FaceTime him so I can get a lift
back and does anyone know where Sprint's
towards we got 10 minutes before sprint
closes Chris sprinkler cause it's Sunday
at 7:00 and who wants to work who needs
hours no one not in this country
everybody's doing good nobody needs any
overtime here not from what I see let's
shut it down early um so I get back to
the house now the phone is gone my phone
is gone I got to go to sprint tomorrow
morning I've only lost my phone twice in
him in a way that I liked the first time
I lost my phone I was it was 2013
I had just moved in in New York City I
was living with a married couple two
comedians who fought bitterly and
eventually got divorced was the second
divorced I had witnessed the first was
my parents I probably played a role in
both I moved in to a five-story walk-up
a tenement building was built in 1911
meaning that there are no elevators
there are stairs you walk up five
stories you get to your apartment our
apartment was a railroad apartment long
hall with rooms on either end they had a
room I had a little shitty room with no
door it had steam heat the building so
there was a steam pipe at the end of my
bed where if I touched it with my foot I
would wake myself up cuz I'd have a burn
on my foot
the kitchen had a shower in the kitchen
there was a shower with a curtain around
it in the kitchen so you would be frying
an egg and somebody would be washing
their ass that was literally the setup
of the apartment somebody would be
washing somebody this woman would be
loofah in her snatch and I would be
heating a baked beans in the kitchen
that's the way that I lived I was 25
years old I was thrilled to be there
because I just the mortgage thing had
collapsed and I had moved into the city
I've been doing comedy about two years
and I just moved into the city and as
soon as I moved into the city God
decided in His infinite wisdom to
destroy Long Island with Hurricane sandy
now I appreciated that I appreciated
that he waited till I left and then he
destroyed my friends and family which I
sanctioned now god of course could not
be held responsible he didn't really
know he was probably trying to get rid
of Long Island but he had no idea he
could not even conceive how durable
these monsters were so they were able to
hang on but it was bad right after
Hurricane sandy
lots of people that I knew their homes
were ruined my grandmother's house was
completely flooded she had to go live
with my aunt Donna for a year most of
the homes in the town that I lived in
Island Park were completely destroyed
boats were floating down the Main
streets in the town that I lived there
was like four feet of water in lower
Manhattan it was bad the financial
district Staten Island all of these
places I've never seen an event like
that I remember as a little kid
hurricanes and I remember people taking
boats down the streets of my town
because I think it was Gloria or
something I can't remember might have
been another one but sandy was the first
thing where you saw the you know
nature's ability to completely just
everything in its path it destroyed and
people's lives were completely ruined I
mean if not ruin whatever you were doing
was pushed back a year at least
now of course my loser friends are still
using hurricane sandy as an excuse in
2019 they are still gone you know
hurricane sandy I was gonna go to school
and then sandy they've been using that
as an excuse forever
I had my I couldn't get my business off
the ground because a hurricane sandy
okay well yeah maybe hey Anthony maybe
and maybe not maybe not so hurricane
sandy happened now where was Timmy Timmy
was living in the fifth floor of the
building in Hell's Kitchen on 45th
between eighth and ninth Avenue right in
the middle of Hell's Kitchen two blocks
from Times Square it was a wild place to
live when these two would fight I would
go walk around in the middle of the
night and just talk to hot dog vendors
and guys that were dressed like Tigger
and Winnie the Pooh the dumb Time Square
characters I'll just walk around smoke
cigarettes at 2:00 a.m. in Times Square
so I mean every subway went there it was
very convenient place to live
but it was crazy you walked out in two
blocks you were just hit with waves of
people and it was still a little sketchy
it was not that sketchy but it was one
of the only areas in New York City
because it was a few blocks from the
Port Authority Bus Terminal you know you
know brick of coke and the [ __ ] little
human trafficking little smash-and-grab
a couple of slashings nothing crazy but
just a little flavor of a city that had
really gotten bland you would see every
now and then you would see something and
you go oh okay it's still kind of New
York here you know like there was a
woman who would just scream on our block
she would just come to our block and
scream at the sky and you go oh okay I
kind of got now if you multiply her by
thousands that was what I guess was like
to live there and then seventies the 80s
but this thing that I lived in we had
bedbugs twice by the way bad bugs baby
it was a rat in our lobby that was there
all the time it was not an ideal place
to live but for me for Comedy Works I
never wanted to be there I always wanted
to be out doing comedy so it worked but
during hurricane sandy was actually one
of the best places to be in the city
okay I didn't leave that whole week
except to go downstairs friends of mine
like oh the lights are out all over the
city you got to see Manhattan in the
dark it's so great you got to walk
across the Brooklyn Bridge we're all in
the waiter hey hey hey hey hey no I sat
and I started watching Breaking Bad oh
you should come back to Long Island and
help people hey hey have we met by watch
Breaking Bad Froyo sandwich Breaking Bad
clean it up figure it out folks figure
it out you want to live on the water
like a badass
so I litter
we didn't leave the two people that I
were living with their families were
from Staten Island so they went to go
help out in Staten Island now help out
god only knows what they were doing
they're probably running people's
pockets
doesn't matter you know these two
weren't exactly you know they weren't in
the Peace Corps let's put it that way so
whatever they would do and they were
probably stealing copper wiring into
buildings I don't know it's not my
business
God love them but you know where there
is chaos this opportunity so good for
them they're like oh you feel guilty
that you're not helping I was like
calling you how are you helping
how are you to helping so I was friends
with one of my best friends we really
don't speak to anymore that I'm kind of
sad about not speaking to was a woman
named Melanie she's interesting woman
she did comedy for a few years she's
very funny and she's very dark and it
wouldn't always work
she talked mainly about plane crashes on
stage and showed a voice like this was
kind of deep she'd go yeah she'd talk
about Delta flight 1791 yeah she would
last thing the pilot said when they were
crashing at San Diego he said this is it
Bobby
love your mom and then the craft yeah
and I thought it was great I thought it
was great you know because why not now
the audience is we're not always in with
some of them were some of them were she
had a great bit of great joke about the
word [ __ ] forget what it was she was
like somebody came up to me and they
were like kind of say [ __ ] she's
like well what if you your brake pads
and they were taught it because brake
pads can [ __ ] it was some vaudevillian
joke and she just kept over taught it
whatever I liked okay she's not gonna
win the Mark Twain prize she was a lot
of fun she loved talking [ __ ] she loved
driving into the city she loved doing an
open mic or two and then having a big
dinner that we couldn't afford and then
driving home in her car did she like she
was like it was an old Volvo that she
worked on she was like kind of lesbian
notch was all over the place but she was
really fun and III she was like my
partner in crime for those two years in
comedy and she lives on Martha's
Vineyard now but she was a lot of fun
and she was somebody that I would call
and we always like we knew what [ __ ]
Long Island was and we knew what
[ __ ] like these Long Island
comedians like these delusional
psychopaths in Long Island I thought
they were gonna get sitcoms and they
thought like the city was gonna come to
them you know and we knew what it was
and me and her used to laugh all the
time and we'd be like these people are
she used to call one of the guys Rob she
was calling fat mouth it was one of the
greatest things ever she goes [ __ ] mouth
Coleman just called him fat mouth cuz he
never shut up and she was fun and
Melanie helped me move into this
apartment she saw it and during
Hurricane sandy I was caught on the
phone with her and talking to her and
these were Griff turrets and I moved in
with Bravo's grifter it was a Grif to
Grif here this was it we were all they
were living in the apartment of a woman
who had a rent-controlled apartment that
let them live there which is not allowed
but it is what it is Melanie always used
to kid around he'd be like is that woman
dead chopped up somewhere where the
closets I'm like probably who cares
by the way our toilet was not in the
apartment it was in the hall of the
building okay the whole of the bill so
you'd have to go out to use a bit and
when you was a tiny little bathroom and
you were just sitting it
I was just enough space to [ __ ] and when
you passed
you'd have to hold the seat up because
it would you had to hold it up and then
pee and like lean against the wall it
was a [ __ ] wild situation sure
Melanie so now I was on the subway this
was little after Hurricane sandy and I
had this crazy commute because I got a
job selling copiers and stat
Niland okay because one thing we know
about Tim Dylan he makes good decisions
and he surrounds himself with great
people those are the two things you know
about me good decisions even better
people
I want a Craigslist for telemarketing
job because I'm a loser
and every loser has most likely
considered telemarketing at one point in
their career of being a loser and I've
been a loser for a long time and I said
and I got on the phone with this nice
guy an older man named James and he goes
you can come to Staten Island you'll
tell a market from nine to one and it's
a little bit of a commute I said [ __ ]
you'll hire me because my deployment was
running out I was on the Obama plan two
years of unemployment four or five a
week for two years 99 weeks thank you
Father
he knew he knew I was working on my
craft and in order to get this I had to
go to back to school at Nassau Community
College at 27 28 years old which was
mortifying Patrice O'Neal talks about he
goes if you see somebody over you know
over 30 in ecology like what the [ __ ]
are you doing I was I was in gym class
at 28 years old at Nassau Community
College being insecure that I wasn't
picked to be someone's [ __ ] tennis
partner at 28 years old in a community
college okay only so I could be a
full-time student so I didn't have to
look for work and I could get my
unemployment that's where I was and then
the government said hey fat-ass this is
over you got to figure it out so I got a
telemarketing job in Staten Island now
this was my commute this was literally
my commute get on the R train I'd wake
up at six o'clock in the morning it was
still dark I would leave my apartment I
would get on the R train at 45th yard
train I think it was the are was it the
one well whatever it was don't you know
these people come good actually the or
doesn't go there you mean it's all fake
isn't it was it the one of the or I
don't know but we went down the south
think it was the one I don't know went
down to South Ferry that was 35 minutes
30 minutes to get down to South Ferry on
a good day maybe a little faster then
it's South Ferry I got off to get on the
Staten Island Ferry does that Nilan
Ferry is the most depressing place in
maybe all of New York because it is a
boat it runs 24 hours a day and it takes
people from the lucky ones from Staten
Island to Manhattan but then there are
some oddities that commute to Staten
Island for work they were unable to
secure positions in the thriving
metropolis that is Manhattan there
wasn't enough they couldn't figure out a
way to work on the island where they
lived so they had to go to Staten Island
and take a 20-minute boat ride passing
the Statue of Liberty but going in the
wrong direction
going the opposite way the hopeful
immigrant journey went one way we're
going the other way back to the old
country then I would get to Staten
Island and then I'd get on the S 74 yes
74 bus and I would sit there on the bus
for one and a half hours till it took me
dropped me off in Tottenville and I went
to go work at reliable office systems in
Tottenville me and Ray did the soldiers
so this whole commute on a good day was
two and a half hours to my $12 an hour
job where I would call up companies ago
hi this is Tim Dylan from real life you
answer the phone hey how's it going
who's
hey this is Tim Dylan with reliable
office systems is this Ben yes hey Ben
how are you I was just following up I
know that we had a conversation a while
ago regarding some of the office
equipment you guys were working on I
mean do you still have a the Ricoh
copiers you're still with them I don't
ever getting a call but yeah we use
those copiers yeah hey Ben I'm sure you
speak to a lot of people I'm not gonna
hold it against you
I do remember talking to you there you
got a pretty voice oh thanks man you're
welcome Ben the ricoh copier that you're
using you have them unleashed that lease
is coming up in about three or four
months I work with reliable we're an
authorized Canon dealer you know Canon
we know Canon hey Ben it's a good
machine yeah it's a good [ __ ] machine
and the reco I bet you have some
problems now here's the thing everyone
hates the copier it's always pricking
and I'm gonna sell you something and
it's always gonna break okay everyone
hates it the copiers always break it's
what they do they just break right yeah
there are these big machines it cost
lots of money inkjet or the [ __ ]
color cop you know all of them I'm like
Ben I want you to look at me I'm not
really a copier sales but I want to help
you go paperless I want to come and
really show you how to evolve your
entire business how to throw out some of
those fax machines let's all go online
let's go Wireless let's do this blah
blah by the canon rep in the area that
wants to come in talk about maybe buying
you here's a scam buying you out of your
existing lease and and getting one of
our way overpriced machines that will
also break almost immediately right
after you buy it but we have great
service and they'll come any time day or
night
now we say this and then you call it
some garlic would you like this thing
piece of [ __ ] doesn't work and two hours
later you call you still not there he
comes in he makes it worse so I go we
got we got our own in-house servicing we
service everything here this is a
depressing selling copiers is when you
go to a sales office you want people to
have actual money you want to see nice
cars in the parking lot right because
you at least are operating under the
delusion that if you
to be good at this you too can drive a
nice car and have a nice Tuscan themed
kitchen with heated floors we can sit at
the table and eat Stromboli that you
brought bought at a grocery store that's
the dream for a lot of people in sales
they can just eat food at their kitchen
table and it can get drunk in the house
and do coke off the granite countertops
that they fleeced a lot of people out of
their own good money to pay for but I
didn't seen it out when I walked in i
walked in i saw a few cars
nothing was great i walked in and they
said our top producer is named Ida
now Ida was an older woman and she
looked at me she was hey kid how are ya
good they go we're gonna see you next I
doubt we want you to hear the pitch I
want you to hear how I - does it Ida
looks at me she goes I'm killing it here
kid how she talks she's like I'm killing
it here because if I keep saving and I
work hard for another six months
I'm gonna finally afford and I'm like
what whoo what do you get in the house
on the water what are you gonna get she
was I could finally afford a car and I'm
like oh [ __ ] she's taking the bus the
top producers taking the bus like I am
she's taking the bus then there was this
other guy Joe real fat guy sweet guy
real fat guy he was also taking the bus
so the whole sales force got on the bus
at the end of the day like the losers we
were okay we got on the bus then like
wouldn't come and we don't stand there
smoking cigarettes in the street in
Staten Island okay I have talked really
fast she get on the fudge you know hey
darlin how are you since I do a reliable
office yes and we talked about the
printing a copy of scanner him to just
say words she just overwhelm him with
words she like cannon cannon good
machine cannon cannon authorized dealer
print a copy of scan of fax call a copy
of code in fact scan a copy account rap
in your area sit down you buy on the
least
copier scanner copier scanner we get
everything they're delivered to you
service 24 hours a day service scan a
copy a color-coded cap and like idiots
on the other end of you like you all
right
send him in Wednesday she'd set a lot of
appointments sometimes a rep would show
up to the appointment and I go I don't
know what that [ __ ] was talking about I
have no idea we don't need nothing she
just kept yelling I just said yeah
whatever send them in Wednesday I don't
know the [ __ ] you are she sell a lot of
junk appointments she said you wanted to
comment ours day they're like oh what
so I on my way there one day in this job
I was very good at it and then they made
me a copier guy like I got this I got
put in the Manhattan office and I had no
money so after three months in Staten
Island I said we're giving you a
promotion you're gonna work for Al al
heard you on the phone it's taking a
liking to you so I go in and they had a
nice office on Bryant Park I go up and I
meet al that al goes hey you don't
because you're making a lot of noise
over there Staten Island now by the way
I don't even know what that means
I set like three appointments but was
better than everybody else right they
used to get people right out of prison
that would like forget what they were
selling you know what I mean if anyone
asked him a question maybe like they'd
be like like one one lady started crying
in the middle of a sales call she just
goes she hung up it was like the guy
called back the guy's just on the phone
call back is she okay what's going on
this is the caliber of people so al said
to me make a lot of noise over there
Staten Island you're gonna come over
here this is the big leagues is it a big
boys kept saying we're big she's the big
time the big leach the big boys because
you see Madeline pointed to some fat
spanish chick Madeline's gonna make six
grand this month I come from mortgages
because it made 40 grand than a month
Madeline's making 6k this month
aren't you Matty you open the door she's
like diving in to one of those salads
that has more calories than a sandwich
with like goat cheese and fried chicken
and cranberries and rat like cranberry
relish and balsamic glaze it's like
chocolate syrup all over it because
Maddie's gonna make six automatics go he
goes he goes we're gonna we're all gonna
go on a trip this year Maddie might
qualify for the trip
Maddie's real excited cuz you know these
sales companies if you do well they take
you to a trip which you could just get
with your own money but it's fun to go
with the whole company cuz always a
chance she'll get drunk and say the
wrong thing and you know so be fired I
don't know what would be the wrong thing
with these guns you could kind of say
whatever you wanted he's like you like
sports like ah not really is a koozie
team Yankees Matt's he's probably asking
every question a big are you gay every
question is that we like to bullets what
do you like you like sports Abby your
sports guy
he said Yankees Mets he named like 40
teams literally he's a Padres like the
baggage I bet you're a bad race guy they
haven't had it they haven't had anything
in a bit but I bet ya that were your
Astros I just want to be like no no no I
suck dead I didn't say that
I just sat in the chair cuz I needed his
gig I was like oh what a good gig I
could work in we worked it was this guy
Joe in our office and it was Joe and Joe
was like a you know these were copier
salesmen so you got to remember their
even the good ones are [ __ ] even the
good ones are not respected but it's the
lowest level of sales office equipment
copiers it's just winning is losing in
that game and this guy al lived where
did I live my Island I was like sick I
got Nikita Nikita
I'll kill people he goes a delivery guy
came in the other day and the delivery
guy put their put the pizza down buddy
the throw is going for my daughter
Nikita squared up with him it's gonna
kill him so girl that's nice al it's
very nice very sweet
so I stir
working there my second day on the
[ __ ] job I'm heading in the office
I'm on the subway I leave my I lose my
phone I leave my phone on the subway
[ __ ] so now I'm [ __ ] I get back to my
apartment the end of the day cuz now I'm
getting all my company emails on my
phone I'm getting my calls from my
clients on my phone I sold like two
copiers in a year to hedge funds one big
office on Park Avenue that had like two
lawyers in it and the rent was like 100
grand a month or these two lawyers like
you know whales of lawyers big I don't
mean fat I mean like they had a lot of
money big client list serious you know
and I would walk into these place I had
one jacket my father got me a jacket it
was covered in bird [ __ ] and had holes
in it that he found he literally found
it and then just gave it to me my father
is like lack of giving a [ __ ] is I can
only admire it now cuz it is hilarious
like my friend Melanie was shocked she
was like I cannot believe your father
gave you this jacket my father was like
I found an old jacket of mine son it's
yours he not holes in it and bird [ __ ]
then he like found it was like it had
mothballs
there was a rotting after sandy and he
just gave it to me so that was I didn't
have any money
I had no money so I was like walking
into these offices in this [ __ ] jacket
and I was so embarrassed I was like you
got to get another jacket like this you
know you know I gotta look the part
like I know al so I leave the phone on
and I'm like I get home I'm so like I'm
like sweating I'm nervous of anxiety I'm
insane I'm like Melanie I [ __ ] get my
roommate my roommate gives me your phone
I got Melanie I'm coming along Island we
got to figure this out say come out to
Long Island we go to my friend Joe
monsters house oh I've talked about a
million times
Melanie goes there's this thing called
Find My Phone on your iPhone she does I
don't know if it'll work but if your
phone is still on
it's going to it'll register where your
phone is so I'm like okay so I go back
I'm smoking sig after sig my hair is
matted with sweat melanie is I wouldn't
let's let's just say not a looker
she has an interesting look it's
interesting she's not she looks like a
like a hippie from Woodstock she was
like overalls and like head shoes and
she was like a big straw hat right total
grifter vagabond type of look I am in a
coat covered in bird [ __ ] with holes on
it with my hairs matter with sweat and
I'm smoking cigarettes and everything is
bad go to my friend Joe's house we go
and find my phone and we go oh my god
it's live it's on and it's in a [ __ ]
nice area she's like a [ __ ] rich kid
stole your phone I said [ __ ] a rich [ __ ]
stole my phone I look at her and she
goes oldest story in the book this is by
the way you have to realize everyone I
know is completely full of [ __ ] do you
understand what I mean like every person
that I've ever in my life met is
completely full meaning that nobody ever
has ever said the words I don't know or
let's wait or let's withhold like
everybody's just here's the way it
happened I see it as clear as day me
included
so well uh it's rich [ __ ] stole your
phone and we're gonna go get it back cuz
it's a rich kid piece of [ __ ] and he
stole your phone and he's gonna panic
when we show up at his house and his
parents it's gonna be a whole big thing
but if it Melanie you're a goddamn
genius so we get in the car
and we had there and Melanie's like I
can't believe it why would he steal it
and I'm like well cause it's thrill the
thrill and she goes you're right I'm
like they just want to steal these rich
Fox then thrill they get high it's an
endorphin rush and I'm like he probably
didn't shut it off cuz he's an idiot
she goes okay she goes but here's what
we should do she goes we should call the
police and have the police ready because
otherwise if we're trespassing or we go
on a property that we're not supposed to
go on we're [ __ ] like we're in trouble
cuz there's a nice area right I'm like
that's a good point Melanie I have a
suspended license I'm like I'm like if
they looked me up they could bag me so
she goes we got to get ahead of it get
ahead of our own cancellation call the
police explain to them that this rich
kid stole your phone we have no proof by
the way no proof explain to them that a
rich kid stole your phone and he's in
his house and we're gonna go confront
him right now and we we just want that's
what we're doing here in this
neighborhood okay
now shall we go to the cop we call the
police
the police pull up they think they're
there to arrest us cuz we both were in
an old Volvo old we both look like
hammered [ __ ] as a guy that guy blade
said that I look like hammered [ __ ]
that old guy Blade 3 watch it great film
the cops go what's the problem
I go officer I was robbed today by the
man who lives in that house he took my
cell phone I was on the way to work I'm
a copier salesman Melanie goes yeah they
stole his phone they took his phone and
then we went on far my iPhone and
there's the iPhones in the house so we
got you gotta get her see ya
okay he goes okay so Melanie and me like
we like Melanie's like you take him in
for this you rest him for this what
happens now
this dealer from the working people
Melanie goes we're just working people
were both smoking cigarettes in the car
the cop thinks the cops three minutes
away from breathalyze in her because he
thinks we're running a scam okay he goes
she goes yes it's stealing from working
people she goes it's not right I go it's
not right it's waving a cigarette in
there because anything goes to either
review of ID we start going back at him
or like what is this now he goes I just
don't know what's happening and so he
takes our IDs checks her ID she's the
driver's side comes back he goes alright
let me knock on the door he goes he
knocks on the door we're sitting there
were like yeah justice comes back out to
the car
he goes are you Tim Dylan yes yeah he
goes why don't you walk up to the house
I walk up to the house one of the
best-looking kids he's probably in his
early 20s opens the door big smile on
his face he's standing there flanked by
two loving parents and he goes hey man
are you Tim Dylan because yeah he goes
dude I called four of your friends I
found your phone on the subway I called
four of your friend to try to get in
touch with you and they all hang up but
they were all drug dealers he's calling
my he's calling my dirtbag friends that
Oh everyone in the world money because I
called all your friends he's like I left
a message with your dad I tried to get
in touch with you you think I'm so happy
you came out of your man this is such a
happy ending and me and Melanie are
standing there looking like [ __ ] on the
steps of this little mini mansion and
this gorgeous kid and his beautiful
loving parents hand me my phone
and the cop just looks at us like we're
total human garbage right and so I say
to kid I'm like this is real nice hey my
uncle he owns a couple of restaurants if
you ever want to go out somewhere let me
know the kids like yeah all right man
thanks just gives me my phone the
parents are like what a nice story isn't
this nice he's like well you didn't
think I stole the phone right I'm like
no we know how this is it out and
Melanie's a girl we see where you live
you don't little phone show then shuts
the door the cops now won't even look at
us cuz they're completely disgusted they
completely disgusted by us we walk back
to the car I get in the car
Melanie gets in the car Melanie just
looks at me she goes yeah I guess we're
the dirtbags huh and I'm like yeah I
guess we are Melanie I guess we are the
dirtbags she goes uh-huh [ __ ] it
and then we just drove away and smoke
cigarettes but I hadn't got my phone
back and it was great I realized there
are good people in the world not many
very few not me not anyone I know but
Melanie was like yeah that kids stupid
you coulda sold that phone I'm like yeah
that [ __ ] [ __ ] should have taken my
phone I'm on this earth to be [ __ ]
over and robbed so what she's driving
back phone and hand but this is the
evener for that this will make up friend
this Russian she's gonna get me unless
somehow tomorrow she shows back up with
the phone in which case I don't know
what to do but that was the first time I
lost my phone I've never had a nice
wallet in my life
I think I've had a few
we're okay uh I had a little when I was
a teenager I had like a little pouch
I just kept Whedon um and then I
upgraded I had you know some garbage
leather wallet I bought at a store put
my fake ID in it now I have just a piece
of [ __ ] it's overloaded with crap
business cards if unimportant people you
know cash has gone through the washer
and dryer you know I mean it's
embarrassing when I take out my wallet
I'm embarrassing I'm ashamed and my life
many of you should be many of you when
you see your wallet says something about
who you are and many of you myself
included you take out your wallet people
look ego you're a mess you're a goddamn
mess you don't care about who you are
you don't present well this is something
I need I was excited when these guys
came on as a sponsor because a lot of my
friends like you good move free rude
whoa no you go and get one okay Ridge
wild is cool and a lot of people have
them if you go to Ridge calm or idge
Ridge calm slash Tim use Tim you get 10%
off okay
lifetime warranty if you love it free
returns if you don't you have absolutely
nothing to lose it's a minimal front
pocket wallet that's designed to
streamline what you carry every day
30,000 five-star reviews it's a better
way to carry your cash and cards 30,000
five-star reviews I mean I need this you
don't need a lot in your wallet
you know if you have a fat wallet like
you know back in the day a fat while it
was like the sign of if you have a fat
wallet now you're mentally ill it's
crazy it's not stuffed with money you
know if you have a fat wallet now it's
stuffed with you know loyalty cards from
Froyo shops and delis you know if they
punch another two sandwiches you get one
free you take out a big wallet now with
[ __ ] falling out of it you look like a
you want a sleek slender wallet few
cards few cards minimalist minimalize
houses now shouldn't even have furniture
the wealthiest people I know have
nothing in their homes Stark it's like a
medical facility only what's necessary
my mother was a hoarder my mother we had
rooms in the house that were stacked
from the floor to ceiling with garbage
McDonald's toys Hess trucks beanie
babies stuffed in plastic bags and
shoeboxes and Gus his table and Gus's
lamp
I mean toys crap board games collectible
said no one wanted to collect I ran so
far the other way I know nothing I've
got a bag of clothes and a horrible
embarrassing wallet and it's time to
even streamline that's the one part of
my mother I have left in me is my wallet
cuz I hoard in my wallet it's this fat
disgusting wallet it's bad I have it
right now I'm gonna take it out and look
at it it's what I don't even know what
kind it is oh yeah it's got a shark it's
a Greg Norman wallet the golfer I think
it's his wallet this Greg Norman sell
wallets I think so yeah it's the shark
dumb wallet you want to streamline folks
all about being minimalist now rich
people don't like it's not about it's
about having a nice space that you don't
clutter up with [ __ ] and that's why the
ridge wallet is so cool man you take it
out people are like oh this guy's about
his business he's in and out he doesn't
have time he doesn't have a bunch of
business cards right you know many
losers I have in my wallet right now I
mean absolute zeros it's somehow have
business cards I mean it's
embarrassment there's nothing I have
nothing essential I got a debit card and
that's hitting a license put him in the
ridge baby put him in the ridge and move
on
I'm telling you 10% off today free
worldwide shipping and returns nobody
returns if they're offering you free
returns nobody's returning this
everybody loves a Ridge wallet literally
30,000 people dig it go to Ridge comm
use promo code Tim link in the
description it is so easy to get and
it's a good gift too
it's fun to turn somebody onto something
and go hey check this out you want to
simplify your life start with your
pocket you know what you gonna have a
little money clip you an approved carry
cash like a teamster no cut it out the
cashless society now all you need is a
little Ridge nice and simple sleek its
sleek suffering trying to lose weight
how about this you get a skinny wallet
start with that start with a thin wallet
and the rest of you will follow suit you
don't need a big clunky piece of I take
out my wallet at restaurants I'm
mortified I'm mortified by how bad my
wallet looks it's beat-up
I've got everything stuffed into one
section of it I don't use any of the
other sections shits falling out how
many wallets you see people it's like
they've been beaten to death I've had my
wallet for years fall out I got to get
on my hands and knees in a restaurant
picking up business cards putting them
back in my wallet don't want goddamn
well I don't need any of them go to the
ridge simple sleek sexy you're not
getting laid if you take out a big hunk
of [ __ ] put it on the bar nobody wants
that
people want a Ridge take it out like
yeah I got a few cards a few important
numbers nothing much
front pocket I'm gonna put my wallet in
my back pocket like a psychopath and sit
on my wallet and I got a front front
pocket barely can tell it's in my jeans
I got skinny jeans Ridge wallet pressed
against my flesh I can feel it I know
it's there it holds my essentials and
they're not a lot you don't need a lot
folks
you don't need everyone you've ever met
in your wallet
you don't need ninety seven credit cards
get a few essential things put him in
the Ridge wallet my mother didn't have a
Ridge wallet now she's schizophrenic so
I don't know but I'm just saying you
know my father didn't have a Ridge
wallet you know you should have lived
his life in debt people didn't take him
seriously second rate salesman not a bad
father but part of that was it he didn't
have a Ridge he didn't have a wallet
that made you respect him he took out a
big you know big clumpy you know worn
leather wallet cards that he probably
were maxed out sticking out of it cash
you know every time you opened it it was
a big thing and it's me too you don't
need to live like that folks you can
change you can be the change start with
a sleek slender sexy wallet with just
your essentials and then get the wife or
the husband and the kids and the house
get the gates at the driveway get the
heated kitchen floor get the helipad the
pool the tennis court
it starts with a ridge wallet and it
ends with you living in a mansion that's
happens okay nobody in a mansion has an
old crap wallet sleek be a stick and
move hustler you know you don't want to
carry anything too heavy around you're
carrying something heavy it better be a
gun I'm not telling you to own a gun and
I hope if you do you do so legally it's
not my business what you do maybe you
have a good reason for having an illegal
gun but it's not my business
Ridge comm / Tim get it I miss Melanie
now
Melanie's now Martha's Vineyard she
became good friends with the daughter of
the guy the role Quint in Jaws was
inspired by a real guy and she became
friends with that guy's daughter and
like lives in a barn in Martha's
Vineyard and like fixes Bill Murray's
car and like does a lot of work and
nobody lives on Martha's Vineyard
year-round she does so she's able to
[ __ ] and I wonder I [ __ ] would love
to call her right now I have her number
I know her number but I don't what what
time is it on the East Coast 1:00 in the
morning I could call her cell is there
any way that it would come out it's 142
in the morning right now all right let's
not there maybe we'll call her another
time yeah she was fun man I miss her but
that's what happens with friends you
know I love that line she goes huh I
guess we're the dirt bugs I said yeah
yeah we are and then we just [ __ ]
drove home but she was fun and she was
with me during that that period and that
was the only time really one of the only
times in life I was pleasantly surprised
most times I am I walk in thinking
something and I go yeah it's yeah I'll
probably kill Epstein yeah yeah I was
like good let him off and they kill him
and by the way
no conspiracy theorist should ever have
to answer any question again after that
you know what I mean like nobody should
ever you should never even like I for
years have been like elections don't
matter this you know or not that they
don't matter but there's a lot going on
and they don't matter fully certain
things matter but there's more going on
is more to the story I've been ringing
that bell for a decade ringing a bell
ding dong ding every conversation every
time I thought I sat down to dinner any
time anyone asked my opinion any [ __ ]
conversation from when I was smoking pot
when I was debating in high school in
college every for I've been dinging that
bell that's why you see these young kids
and the far left and the far right
they're finally they're waking up it's
their first awakening of how [ __ ] up
everything is and they're like you know
a lot of them are being radicalized into
going all these different directions
because this is the first time they've
realized man it's impossible to bury
your head in the sand now with the
amount of information you have you just
know that things are [ __ ] up you know
it you can research it you can you know
the I's are dotted the T's are crossed
and they can feel they feel it they can
sense it they understand they don't know
what like I would say all the time I
don't know what happened but I don't
think it's what you guys think maybe
they what I think but it ain't what do
you think that's been my life so like
when people get really invested in
anything now a conspiracy it's not that
I'm black pilling I'm not telling you
not to believe in anything I'm not
telling you not to be active I'm not
telling you to not try to elect whoever
you think is gonna be better I'm telling
you that from my own personal experience
I've been ringing
Bell in the town square for years
talking you know just going hey man I
don't think it's like that I think it
might be like this come here look at
this
read this watch this documentary here's
a book
here's another but here's an article and
you get to a point where you go well
okay what else would you like from me at
this point you know I've had the people
on the show I've conducted the
interviews I've recommended the books I
told you that it's not that I don't care
it's that I don't care there's a
difference not that I don't care I don't
care I can't emotionally invest myself
in this idea that there's going to be
justice because every fact that I can
look at that I can unearth tells me to
be incredibly skeptical of most of what
you read and hear and see so listen man
I figure I [ __ ] on boomers with the
self-awareness to know that we're not
serving anything we're not serving up
anything better
our generation ain't gonna will become
them they got a better deal than we did
but we can demand accountability but
what does that even mean what are you
gonna do I'm not asking I'm what are you
really gonna do nothing you do if you do
something violent it will only make
people more sympathy
pathetic to the idea that the state
needs to come in and take away more of
your rights that's the only thing
that'll happen if you do something
violent okay if you work within the
system good for you good on you
hopefully that well I don't think people
should ration insulin I don't believe
any of that but understand the changes
that will happen
will matter and they'll be meaningful
but they'll still kill the pedophile
king before he's tells the truth like
that is not gonna change
you're not gonna I don't care what
public demonstrate like it does no
you're not really gonna move the meters
in that regard
it doesn't seem does it seem possible
from where I sit from what I'm looking
at because the people on the other side
will go to any links you will not
because what are you gonna be got a
family you got kids you got a job you
you know they will go to any lengths and
they have the resources and they will do
whatever they wanted to eat you know you
listen doesn't mean you shouldn't be
active or informed or whatever but I
kind of take that to heart what
everyone's like oh you're black pilling
people and it's Neil ISM it's not
interest it's not Neil ISM it's not me I
don't you tell me where your hope caught
you defend your hope you defend that why
am i defending what's a rational
response to the facts of the day you the
onus is on you the burden is on you you
tell me what signs you see
and don't give me some cueing on
horseshit
tell me realistically what's gonna
change what do you tell me I'll listen
I'm open I just don't and I see these
young people some of them are my family
all these people they're getting here
it's [ __ ] up now so I can't believe
and this is [ __ ] up
buddy it's been a little I feel it gets
boring it's boring after a while there's
more to life I hate to say it there's
more to life than figuring out everyday
how you're being [ __ ] short answer
every way they got every way that they
can they will they don't care human life
no value not it no value to them it
means nothing to them it means nothing
these are the people that brought the
Nazi doctors over to experiment on
children now yeah aboard the cold war we
had sure you went out fine you
extenuating circumstances
notwithstanding somebody had to stand in
a room with a lab coat on and torture
kids for the greater good so those are
the people that you're up against those
those crew that crew and then they play
golf on Sunday then they go to a country
club and talk about your kids going to
school this is who you're up against
you're up against senators that that
commit horrible abuses to children and
then go on Face the Nation and talk
about taxes
yeah like well or the business climate
you need low tight and these people
doing coke 48 hours ago in a mansion in
DC with child's horse running around
and I don't say that to demean the
children it's a bad scene it's a bad
scene folks it's no good live a
meaningful life do what you want to do
out there you want Bernie in get him in
maybe it maybe you know but I think
Bernie be good
I'd be reset I don't I'm not a hater I'm
open to a lot of what that guy says I
like him
Trump's not doing nothing in the realm
of like you know you want to talk about
with the Epstein's and the wars and the
die he'd say they already go to red they
try to go to Iran they want to go to
Iran now and Trump to his credit is not
going full-on with that plan now maybe
if there's a Pietschmann heats up he'll
be like balm at all I don't know I you
know I barely have faith in my family
and friends if you have it in you to
have faith in a political leader god
bless you especially one running this
country good good you're a better man or
woman or non-binary I don't want to say
thing you're a better entity than I am
if you can truly with a straight face I
remember me and my friends used to laugh
our asses off we'd get stoned and we
would laugh we would drive around our
town and these idiots would put the gore
and Bush on the lawn and everybody would
end and and in 7-eleven would have Gore
coffee cups and Bush coffee cups and
people would throw coffee at each other
and they were all so it was big deal and
maybe now if you look back and go well
um you know I was having this argument
you on that day like well if if if Bush
hadn't won who wouldn't you know if Gore
won we would not have gone into Iraq we
wouldn't have gone to MIT maybe that is
all true
but then I would remind you that Gore
was the vice president for the rapist
for eight years
who was on Epstein's playing a bunch
whose wife never met a war she didn't
like who bombed an aspirin factory
because Monica Lewinsky ran a mouth so
gore yes probably would have been better
than Bush but let's not like live in a
world where like gore was this guy that
was like gonna open the you know change
everything I mean let's get real it was
just funny I get in a lot of I get a lot
of debates with people where and and
more so recently where I I think you
know I think the young people their
activism is good III it would be nice if
it focused less on the shape of skulls
or on the other side rehabilitating
Joseph Stalin's legacy although I know
that I mean I you know it'd be nice it
would be nice if those weren't the two
options that the kids were now getting
involved in you have one side is like
getting getting a day like we need to
restore the Holy Roman Empire I'm like
well well why Catholic Church is done
more to [ __ ] kids then they can't
epstein in them couldn't even come near
the church as the great rake up said you
know the church probably called the
people who were like why don't we go
back to handling it please because your
private contractors are not doing the
job they need to be doing this is a
whole idea that if we just return to
traditional religion and put more power
in the hands of the church laughs and
then on the other side they're like well
listen now had some ideas and you're
like oh is oh okay because it's like and
I get it because you do reaction to
something being so [ __ ] is to run in
another direction of of radicalism and
go
okay well there's some unifying theory
out there that if we just adhere to and
we put into practice everything would be
okay and then human nature would be
totally we could get rid of all of the
things the corruption the greed you know
we could get rid of all of that and
listen maybe you stamp out some of it
I don't a kid like David Hogg I don't
hate but then you look at what he's
tweeting and you look at these general
vague statements today he wrote your
heart on Twitter is like your hardest
day is your most important day so that I
tweeted that and I'm like that means we
keep the guns is that well cuz you're
saying the hard days are the ones that
matter well I mean ah but my point there
is not so much to [ __ ] on him it's to
say these vague meaningless platitudes
you tweet all day don't mean anything
they're meaningless
you know you retweeted suddenly said I'm
sick of living in the divided States
familiar
are you running for president in
nineteen that's his boomer slogans I've
ever heard I'm sick of living in the
divided States about hey David what are
you to say something real stop having a
PR team fire out your tweets that are
meaningless let's how about let's not
destroy the earth to that be above what
would what's the plan anyone can do that
anyone can just tweet horseshit all day
but it takes a special person to find a
phone and give it back it takes a very
special person
I don't know any of those people you
know I don't know a person that would
find a phone and give it back I wish
everyone the best I really do go and
figure out your life
I don't know what to tell you get
involved in the things that excite you
get involved in the things that you
think matter if you want to hunt down
conspiracies go do it if you want to
find out that all the monsters in the
closet and under the bed are indeed real
and worse than you thought go do it if
you want to go find that darkness it'll
be there I've gone down those roads and
I found it and other than getting the
word out and having a little bit of a
platform and talking about it I don't
truly know what other than like you know
I think so a lot of people when they
feel powerless they can [ __ ] these
queueing on crazy things to go no it's
common because they're they're incapable
of feeling they're incapable of feeling
despair and and which is I don't feel
despair because I am personally doing
the best that I can but I think there's
a lot of people out there that realize
how [ __ ] up the world is and their
response to that is concoct fairy tales
and fables about that it's actually
getting better we just don't see it
because there's great forces fighting an
unseen war and battle and Donald Trump's
one of them they're all fighting behind
the scenes and when you win it's when
the grand plan is finally revealed I
mean it you know if you get if you can
really do that if you think that's
what's going on if you think that's was
gonna Trump was dancing with Epstein at
a party do you think that he cares do
you think Donald Trump was making waves
for anybody involved in anything it's
all
same [ __ ] dirty money it's all the same
[ __ ] guys yeah maybe he you know
hopefully he was on the island he wasn't
you know but at the end of the day it's
like he's not making waves for these
people so I don't know man I don't know
maybe we need an alien thing and we
start seeing each other as human beings
again and we don't divide by race and
Creed and you know I don't know and
class as much even though that's you
know it's you know obviously it's
unavoidable when there's people you know
that can't get health insurance I
understand that but maybe that is what
makes humanity leap forward maybe it's
an outside threat maybe it's just the
evolution of technology to a point where
we are able to be more involved and but
that means that like are the human
characteristics that distract us and
like maybe we become more highly evolved
efficient robots and then those robots
maybe give a [ __ ] I know no I think it's
just gonna be a bunch of fat robots just
a bunch of fat Bionic robots running
around I don't know I mean you know I
was talking to a friend who lives in
London and he was like I was talking
about going over there to do some shows
and he was like listen everybody knows
the reality of what's going on everybody
knows that the royal family is full of
[ __ ] Prince Andrew there's this article
that he wanted he was going to EPSA
Stavros had a great read from Compton
Prince Andrew was going to epstein his
latest trip to FC was to end their
friendship Stavros had my latest trip to
Buffalo Wild Wings was to tell them I'm
no longer eating wings everybody knows
what's up there's really not like this
whole idea that we just need to find out
you know fat people know why they're fat
most of them you're not in the dark
don't wake up one day a well and go what
happened I went to bed yesterday all
right a six-pack you know but it's what
do you do with the knowledge that's the
real question what can you really do
with the knowledge and I guess it's just
to put it out there as much as you can
in the hopes that but I think the future
of the country and I could be wrong is
some type of it's gonna be will dissolve
I feel like will will break up into
maybe they like the Colin Quinn thing
where he goes maybe you'll just break up
into regions
III don't know maybe that will never
happen maybe it'll be kind of like Great
Britain where there's a you know people
know that it's just past peak and the
things you know it's all pomp and
circumstance and other royal family the
royal wedding the royal baby he will
have a gay president will have a trans
print you know we'll just go down a line
we'll have a woman of color in a little
bit but it'll be a very you know
ceremonial thing you know and well I
mean or we just get into the big one
with China I don't know but part of what
I think attracted me to whether you I
don't want to call them conspiracies but
like to alternative history and things
like that is that I was getting the real
information I was saying well this is
really why things happen
so what I then can't do is use that as a
basis to concoct theories and fables
that make me feel better which is what a
lot of you seem to love doing because
you need to do it you're like well I
like that well no it went okay well you
just tell me the plan you share with me
and it can't be some crazy batshit thing
you ran on the thread and you become one
of these you know all the people I used
to do drugs with they all have facebook
profile pictures talked about keyword on
hey these are people that I used to just
freebase cocaine with and they wouldn't
feed their children and now they're all
talking about Q and I mean listen what
do I know is there a guy leaking from
everybody's leaking information over
there everybody trying to leak their way
out of jail probably but it's like get
insulin get health insurance fight that
battle
start small let's get to a point where
we can expect the government there not
poison us with food and everything like
that but you know it is what it is folks
I you know I don't want people you know
I greatly I'm happy that young people
are getting involved and I hope that I
don't know I mean what do you ever think
about what this country looks like in 30
years yeah what do you think it looks
like it's hot it's so much hotter I mean
Alaska will be like beachfront property
probably right maybe yeah most people
are probably in Montana the Southwest is
probably pretty unlivable places like
Texas pretty unlivable you know I just
think about like the temperature I just
think about like have you seen first
performed that guy know what is that
that movie with Ethan Hawke where he
he's a priest and he meets a guy who's
all about climate breakdown and
everything
and that guy well I don't want to spoil
the movie for people who gives you [ __ ]
the guy ends up killing himself because
he can't he can't justify bringing a
child into this world because he gets
his girlfriend pregnant and he's all
into like the ice caps melting and
everything he kills himself
Ethan Hawke was a guy who was trying to
help him out through all of his
depression and stuff and then he
eventually goes crazy and he realizes
that his church is backed by a mega
church which is backed by this oil
company that's just destroying the earth
and he he becomes basically like he
thinks he's gonna be a terrorist and
like bring this whole thing down I won't
reveal the ending but it's it's a great
movie came out last year well so III
think of the country like that just an
unlivable place I didn't know enough
about climate to know what's gonna
happen um he's very possible that you
can have a lot of countries not looking
great sea level rise you know it seems
to be like the global economic collapse
where you can't really predict when I
like we race at egos yeah you bring kids
into the world but then somebody goes
then what happens in rigo's they burn is
what it is nobody gave a [ __ ] about us
apparently give a [ __ ] about us I mean I
think I have to go to New York for a
week I don't know I've been I mean IIIi
just got off the road with Burton I'm
Michael Turner I'm still deciding I
might not I might just go for four days
see my mother and do some shows there I
need to be I need to get a little New
York juice I need to walk around a
little I need to get on stage a bunch I
need to just get a little juice not
literal juice that's not um I need to
just
I mean grub might oughta grow up tonight
they just didn't come the driver just
stole the food again it's the second
time a grub up drivers stolen food are
people so desperate now for food that
they're signing up with the grub up
accounts are just steal dinner it means
that what's going on probably you get
away with that if you do it I've done it
you can do it a million different times
yeah
yeah it's fine Devin does it all the
time yeah well you just turn your phone
off go eat everybody's food you just
turn your phone off go home just eat the
food yeah
great where is Devon what's he doing
he's at Babs I guess yeah I mean the
uber driver today the grub pup I'm like
I just need there's something great
about New York that we remember when you
went and it just the bacon and eggs that
guy made in that diner so quick so quick
and then we went got those sandwiches
they were done before we ordered them
yeah there's something about being in an
environment where like you have to be
competent it's required it's sharp like
you're sharp and there's something about
that then I mean I'm in LA for the long
haul I love it here but I I think I need
a little dose my living situation is
very interesting without saying too much
about it it's odd it's very odd I don't
know what's going on here I'm living in
a divorce literally I moved into like a
separation I don't know what's happening
and it's on the communication is not
good and I you know and I've lived in a
lot of wild situations but I'm at the
end of these and I'm the next place I'm
gonna live I've just got to live alone
and in a quiet non drama place and a lot
of these crazy people I surround myself
with are funny and wild and they are
great material and I'm getting too old
I'm funny enough now I have enough of
them I can you know you start paying a
price eventually for being around crazy
people crazy people are funny I mean I
was at dinner the other night with a
bunch of people they were like nice who
were couples
I'm so [ __ ] boring you know he's a
good people like sweet nice people those
types of people need to have a few
drinks to get a little loose you know
and then you know they're still boring
but they're like sweet and nice and
I was just like oh yeah I mean I've just
spent my life around hucksters thieves
liars cheaters carnival people the
circus crazies drunks vagabonds drunks
[ __ ] derelict and I really wouldn't
have it any other way but at this point
34 or 35 hundred not all that many more
85 I got 35 I don't even know but I
really don't know my age I'm set with 85
what am i 34 35 you're 34 I think you
turned 35 in January who cares the point
is I do but I've spent my life you need
you start thinking when you're 35 do you
start thinking you going is this it like
is this what it's gonna be just Looney
Tunes and everyone in my business I love
them all and by you know you know me I
don't mean that at all
I could mean I could mean nothing I
don't mean anything less than that I've
never met anything less than the
statement I've just said nothing nothing
less but everyone in my business is
insane I don't care if they're in
Ferraris or but you get to a point you
go I don't know I mean they just want to
live one [ __ ] day and the reality of
that kid and his parents who found my
phone and just tried all day to get it
back to me you know it's just like as
you get older you're like oh that's nice
you know you see all these people
partying I just on the road with Burt
you see everyone partly people just go
out and party and get shit-faced
that's it they just want to get loose
they work Monday through Friday so that
they can go out and get hammered you
know get [ __ ] up fall asleep in an
uber you know I was in an uber one day
and the guy goes yeah I keep smelling
salts and my thing to wake people up so
I could kick him out of the car
cuz they pass out in the car because
everybody gets out and gets so [ __ ] up
that's what it is for a lot of people
they just want to get the people's
brains and made out of play-doh and then
you didn't we have to expect that
they're all gonna say it you know I mean
but I think about that sometimes I'm
like god what a [ __ ] I got to start
really looking at people that I know are
saying I will make friends with people
knowing full well that there's that's I
go oh that's a psychopath that's a
psychopathic personality clinical you go
that's clinical psychopathic personality
it's a it's a diagnose it's a diagnosis
you could make and I'll become friends
with a person like that and then you
know you're down the road I'm like oh
they're not you know like knowing full
well knowing full well that these are
people that I get new arrangements with
knowing full well that because they're
fun they're just fun and you know you
start to realize if fun has a real price
fun has a real there's a real price tag
on fun fun is expensive fun is very
expensive I've had a lot of fun I very
few meaningful relationships with people
but I've had a lot of fun and I do have
some meaningful relationships with
people but I look around a lot of people
I'm around and I'm like god these people
are so they don't even they can't even
control how crazy they are anymore
they're just they're just on a ride that
they've lost control of and they're just
doing their best to still kind of like
you know you know make a fun face for
the picture when we all go down the
roller coaster but you know
and you know so I think at this point
I'm gonna I'm gonna transition to a
woman I thought about it I mean you know
I mean people seem happy
you seem happy if you fully embrace
insanity
you know if you're like 350 pounds 400
pound and and you just say that's me
that's me my dick doesn't work I can
barely move the only thing I enjoy is
drinking paint thinner you know I just
want to walk around this casino and what
would money do I look at all these
people casinos I'm like what would money
even do for you you can't move
what would money do I guess it would be
nicer it's just sit in a mansion and eat
tater tots cuz that's what they serve as
a side and 30 40 percent of the
restaurants in America's tater tots
you know you look at people you go what
what do you what do you hope will you
just become one of those old fat racist
son Long Island sold guys who sit in a
bar who's been just handed everything
their whole life but they still find
fault they still find like they've been
denied they've had the easiest lives if
anyone they've been given houses and
cars no show Union jobs or corporate
jobs they show up then they go to some
Steakhouse every night they just get
hammered eat steak and just get fatter
and fatter the dick shrink up and go
inside their bodies to keep barely [ __ ]
their wives anymore and they're heroes
Donald Trump they go they love Donald
Trump because he's calling because it's
these Mexicans and he's giving it to
them it's like you you can barely move
from one room to the next
you hurt you're completely a body is
being eaten by cancers and and you they
still they just they they just you know
somehow they do it somehow they do it
we'll wrap this up folks I don't know
what episode this is gonna be I don't
know if it'll be the patreon I don't
know beautiful being a regular episode I
don't know where it's gonna go I don't
know what's gonna happen I don't know
when the Book of Revelations is gonna
come true I would like you to buy
tickets to my live shows Tim de la
comédie calm my little Jewish nerd that
built the site we don't even it's not
even a mobile site I'm gonna [ __ ]
break his head doesn't work on mobile it
like doesn't show up the right way
the dates had cut off you know again I
could have spent money to do this I had
free labor now they're [ __ ] scream at
this kid you know I should have spent
the money we gotta start to emerge yeah
life in the big city shirts mm-hmm
that's what it is that's really what it
is everything we've talked about life in
the big city
listen if Dennis was alive today he
would look at the absent accusers and
they would say we've been denied justice
again Dennis would take a swig of cheap
wine out of a Burger King cop you light
a Marlboro red and you'd go honey life
in the big city because that's what it
is this is life in the big city this is
what it is I mean you know I hope you
find everything out there if you're
listening to this I hope all of your
dreams come true except some of you
because I know what those dreams aren't
there to kill me or kill someone or
detonate a suitcase nuke in that case I
would rather heat those dreams not come
true if your dream is peace happiness
health maybe a little lake then that's
fine is this
this other fat cat it's not around cats
I mean animals are just i-i've just
showered on animals I don't want to see
animals dogs and cat just don't want
them in homes anymore
you know I just I really don't want I
don't want anything to do with them I
like them but I want them away from me
they're filthy they're just filthy you
know so there you go that's for the PETA
people at the edge the animal rights
people I think they do it right in China
they eat dogs they eat people and that's
why they're number one I should do a
tour in China should move to China what
if I show up to China you know Chinese
people are now getting nice and fat you
got a look at Malaysia if you're a bored
go to Malaysia's Pizza Hut they put fish
heads on the Pete it's like they're the
most creative people because they're
like well we want you to get fat but we
know you need to eat some of our food
too so we're gonna put like seaweed
wrapped fish heads in the stuff crust
pizza just so you guys can feel
comfortable getting it down and that
kind of the kind of ingenuity is what I
respect I need to start marketing like
that it's day one without a phone what
are we gonna how I get it what am I
gonna do tomorrow just show up at Sprint
and just try to show up just catch up I
guess bring your computer I don't know
you can't do insurance dude it took me
like four days through insurance to get
the phone through the mail it's crazy
stupid I can't do that I need to get a
phone will you send me a phone people
you mail me your [ __ ] phones you lazy
piece of [ __ ] what if we got a thousand
phones now don't do that
all right folks tyll tyll tyll next time
the future is so bright you gotta wear
shades this is an addendum this is an
addendum to the episode this is an
addendum say it with me now this is an
addition up I mean damn not you not you
I want the people in the cars to sing
and the people listening in their homes
not you you don't speak or you don't
sing folks here's the addendum I woke up
this morning and I said what I really
wanted to say about politics is it the
way people vote is usually the most
predictable and the least interesting
thing about them
politics is base level it's ugly it's
primordial it's if it's from our reptile
brains it really is if you're an evolved
human being and many of you listening
like I'm not and I get that but if
you're an evolved human being it's
impossible to not get bored with this
and and that's kind of what I mean I'm
interested in a lot of things I'm
interested in people that transform
themselves that went through something
and came out the other side better
stronger more capable I'm interested in
people that have built businesses I'm
interested in great art I'm interested
in food I'm interested in a million
different things but the retail brand of
American politics is just vulgar it
really and I'm not saying it doesn't
have its place and it's not important
but to fixate endlessly on the horse
race between Democrats and Republicans
publicans and to spend your entire life
doing that is wasting your brain it's
what why do you think people have Rogan
show they love it for a million reasons
one of the reasons is that he has varied
interests and the show caters to that
he's genuinely curious that's why that
every show that's simply about politics
has some kind of cap you hit a wall
that's why I cared about politics as a
kid and it's like a young adult as a
young man and I still to an extent care
about it and I care about the
implications of it but when you watch it
for any period of time you start to
notice patterns emerge you start to
notice the nature of it feels cyclical
it has seasons it's like a television
show it has a cast they bring on new
cast members some cast members leave
some never leave it becomes predictable
to an extent that's why Donald Trump was
so exciting to people because he came in
and it was unpredictable and it felt
wild and it felt like because he was
saying things that you would never heard
a politician say before and he was
saying them in a way that you had never
heard anybody speak that was running for
president but when you look at why
people vote for whoever they vote for
well you travel around the country I
think the people that truly believed in
in the political system and this is
nothing wrong with it they believe in
people they believe in people and now
that's good but that's where we are
going to diverge that's where our
opinions would have a divergence of
opinion I believe that most people bless
their hearts are pretty simple and they
want to be herded they
want to be treated like cattle this is
what they want it's it doesn't mean that
I'm better than other people
I am but it doesn't mean that it means
that it's real like when you look at the
system and you look at the people that
are able to maneuver in this system you
know they're very good at presenting a
side of themself to people and what I've
always been interested in is what are
those people like behind closed doors
what do they really like whether they're
in Hollywood or whether they're in
Washington or who are they really and
how do they really get to where they got
and what do they really believe do they
believe in anything or are they just
kind of like a liquid that takes the
shape of their container
some of them do believe in things some
of them are ideologues some of them
aren't some of them are sociopaths some
of them wouldn't know some of them have
never met themselves those are some of
the most successful people I know
they've never even met themselves so but
politics I mean the great line from
succession egos politics that's what
comes out the [ __ ] how wrong is that
how wrong literally is think about the
beautiful things in the world love
calamari all of the things that are
worth more than politics
it's the obsession with the right and
wrong I'm right you're wrong I'm on this
team you're on that I'm gonna beat you
it's a boring Pete evolved human being
and I don't I mean so that's where I'm
at it's ugly its base level most of it
it's the expression of like the darkness
in us it's completely run by fear or
most of it and there are rare glimpses
of humanity and beauty but go look at
anything else
it's much easier to glean a little hope
for mankind than it is just simply
looking at you know what Elizabeth
Warren said good for her not hating on
her I'm just picking heard she just
floated it in my mind but that's what I
meant to say it's not taking away
anything from anybody that's an activist
or anybody that's traded in a lucrative
profession to genuinely help people I
don't know any of those people and I
know a few of them I actually do know a
few of them who walked away from
lucrative professions to actually help
people
okay that's none of the people you see
on Twitter none of them it's none of the
blue checkmarks it's none of the people
that are highlighted by our media it's
none of the people it is it is
predominantly people the toil and the
shadows people that you will [ __ ]
never know about maybe it'll be a
documentary about them and there
probably won't be okay so those people
are fascinating and interesting to me
but it's it's really what you think it
is that's the thing about policy it's
actually exactly what you think it is it
not the real story not the inner
workings of it but why people voted for
Donald Trump why they voted for Hillary
click pretty easily with a butter knife
you get just falls right apart you you
get it you can see why you can I want my
guns okay good
no one should have a guy it's like
alright that's where we're at you know
no abortions everyone has an abortion
okay that's where we're at it doesn't
hold my interest and I if it holds your
interest good for you it did hold my
interest when I was 19 and smoking pot
every day and it was kind of funny and
me and my buddies were you know watching
the the bush Kerry election and we were
watching cable news and it was kind of
cartoonish we're watching Chris Matthews
there was a great show called MSNBC late
night and they'd have like Ron Reagan's
son who's effeminately gay but as a wife
and he's like my father about Stabat and
they would have like people like Steve
Earle the folk singer and
Treena vanden Heuvel who ran the nation
and then pat buchanan and he just be
like the [ __ ] of the [ __ ] watts hot
man the [ __ ] and they would all sit
together in Central Park and a Bill
O'Reilly on the other channel would yell
and scream and talk about traditionalism
and at a certain point you realize that
everybody's collecting a check that's
kind of all that's happening you know
that's what it is so that's my addendum
seek beauty seek truth join the patreon
come see my live shows by the merch that
we're having ready seek beauty and truth
stop spending time in the American
political vote gar it's gross
have some self-respect you're on the
planet for a certain amount of years how
much you're gonna waste it staring at
Rachel Maddow you're wasting your life
they don't give a [ __ ] they don't your
friends your family they don't care
about you so can you imagine that
political figures do your best friends
and your family barely can't they barely
care they barely care about you and you
think it's [ __ ] bado
O'Rourke does we're turkey organs hombre
doe bado O'Rourke what the [ __ ] is that
what kind of name is that his real name
is something else his father named him
bado so he'd have a chance to be a
politician because bado sounds Mexican
and then a Roarke it sounds like a dumb
Mexican restaurant like that's also an
Irish pub like that kid that was on The
Tonight Show when he said a taco
Flanagan's or whatever that's what it
sounds like I don't know what happened
to that guy see Dad where is that guy
anyway so but people move to LA and they
fall in the Pacific you might not be
dead what do I know
that's the addendum folks that's where
it's at that's where I'm at I have an
uncle they're like you know what am i
answer it's like I like this bait oh you
shut up
call your son I like bado I mean at what
point do you [ __ ] get real and
realize that it's a [ __ ] it's a
circus I like to beta we state that yes
there's a lot of thing I just think he'd
be a nice change of beta or Roark get a
hobby
go paint seashells I don't give a [ __ ]
what you do if you're not collecting a
check from this [ __ ] and you're not
fighting for something you truly believe
in stop passively following this like
it's sports or like it's a reality show
you know how many times I sit down with
people and they're like they're all
incensed then they're all ready to go
and they don't have a goddamn fact and
they're just ready to start and they're
not and they're angry about nine other
things in their life that they won't
tell you what they're about so they just
channel it into some political diatribe
that makes no sense to anyone at the
table they start yelling and screaming
you know as somebody the other day was
going off about when they pulled out of
the Paris Accord the climate agreement
I'm like do you even know what it is I
can't believe we pulled out of the
apartheid Bible do you know what it is
I'm not saying it's gonna bear that we
pulled out do you know what it is or did
you hear someone and now you're
repeating it cuz you're really angry
about god only knows what so that's my
point
you know it is what it is it's been
interesting to see as a guy that's
always looked at the inner workings we
should have had more food that was like
not a lot of food they gave us that
restaurant but as somebody that kind of
looks at like the conspiracy side it's
been a while a couple of years it's been
a wild couple years but I mean it's like
Epstein getting capped that's like
almost my series finale that's like the
end I'll still talk about [ __ ] I'll
still do episodes about [ __ ] I'll still
bring people on interview of them but
the way it all just [ __ ] went like
the way it went you go alright hey I'm a
passenger on the ship I am a passenger
on the ship I'm watching a movie and
they decided to kill off one of the main
characters in the movie well okay guess
we'll watch another channel let's watch
dozy cat that's much it bottom [ __ ]
that's ma ho that's what I'm doing I'm
bopping around a corner on that's my ho
she's my blue blue blue blue blue and I
suggest you do the same I suggest you do
the same
that's my [ __ ] Bubba
bado
oh ho I mean like he's [ __ ] women
middle-aged women getting wet because of
that bait Oh O'Rourke he's was a failure
he's out he failed
he's up there talking saying it you know
talking in Spanish trying to be you know
that's how dumb they think you are
turn it off
he's standing out there well uh me gusta
can turn it off
they think you're a fool they have no
respect for you as the thinking organism
they have none and you are treating them
you're giving them the power and the
respect you're sitting on your fat ass
and watching them talk turn it off
new show that's my chick my bottom [ __ ]
new show post Malone now Jake and Logan
turn it off they don't treat you with
respect
they don't care Epstein's dead oops
again and but they don't care but you
care you're sitting there like you're
either having a good faith you're being
dealt with in good faith it's like
people going into Enron knowing what
they knew
two months after imploded don't go be
like what's the deal with these pipeline
I don't think you're being honest here
you know that yeah what what will it
take for you people to turn the channel
focus on whatever you need to focus on
that is don't these people are not it's
not I don't know what else to tell you
Joe Biden is senile Bernie makes him
sense he's 90 is there anyone that it's
a 90 that makes sense he's a good dude I
like him I'd like him to win probably
would be a good idea probably you know
what do you think would happen how long
he lasts what a month fourth [ __ ]
that guy they found the way to get to
him or he'd spend in ten years he spent
eight years there he lived till 106 and
you know he'd get a free community
college for everyone it's not it the
country it's not there isn't you go all
over the country and you realize pretty
quick people don't want it to work they
don't want it to work they just want to
beat other people they don't
want anything to actually change and get
better some of them do but the vast
majority of them don't they're selfish
simple cretins not the one to go to my
shows not those people and not the ones
that listen to my podcast but the others
they don't care they don't it doesn't
mean anything today they just want to
sit on their fat ass and eat Pringles
while Elizabeth Warren tells them how
she's gonna take it to trump or they'll
they want to sit there and watch Donald
Trump tell them that he's draining the
swamp what does that even mean what
swamp is he drinking whose still
believes that he's gonna drain the swamp
what what are you talking about I have
more respect for like like the human
traffickers the Coyotes that are
bringing people over here they have more
of an understanding of what's going on
then anyone that works at the New York
Times or CBS the coyotes that bring over
the people have more of an understanding
of the facts on the ground than anybody
that went to Yale so it's literal
retards have a better take on what's
going on now than then people that went
to Harvard's Kennedy School of
Government literal retards change the
channel
embrace what it is embrace this is where
you live in now this is where you live
in you're not living on the come-up
you're living as it starts to slip away
it's slipping away people are too fat to
fit in the car the economy that we have
left is based on gambling
okay I don't know what else to tell you
there are people without health
insurance in this country that have no
health insurance and they think it's
great they think it's fine because
Trump's training the swamp and he's
gonna put Obama in Gitmo cuz a guy on
reddit said so in a poem
those are your fellow citizens those are
the your fellow citizen if you work just
to put in perspective let's say you
worked in a company and you were on a
team and you had to accomplish a goal
and a few of the people on your team
instead of coming to work early and and
getting ready and preparing themselves
and reading all the emails instead of
doing that they were standing in the
parking lot eating their own [ __ ] and
you had to go up to them and go hey I
know that you guys are eating your own
[ __ ] number one that's bad for you
number two we really gotta put our heads
together and do this we got to get this
done we got to hit our numbers so could
you go home and shower and and they they
just kept eating their own [ __ ] and they
were covered in their own [ __ ] you went
you know I don't know how this team's
gonna work I just can't seem to reach
them because they're eating their own
[ __ ] in the parking lot
and then you go up and you tell your
manager and he goes where's the where's
bill bills in the parking lot eating his
own [ __ ] again well will you go down
there and explain to bill how important
this is bill doesn't care see bill
doesn't care and you can't fire bill cuz
they're not paying bill you see so
that's my addendum to the episode change
the [ __ ] Channel think about other
things I don't know what they are I can
tell you what they are you talk to
people people don't have any interest
your fellow citizens don't really have
an interest and it's not only these
animals that we all talk about these fat
people
and I'm not Shin on fatties I'm fat I'm
just I'm talking about like it's
especially the people that live in nice
homes with nice clothes and shiny cars
and kids that go to good schools they
don't have they have zero interest in
fixing a thing
zero and then the people that are
totally [ __ ] they don't they don't
know how and no one can really teach
them how and the people that try to
teach them how easy to get co-opted or
they get murdered so you know that's
magic my bottom [ __ ] she's my ho start
calling yourself a ho if anyone brings
up politics you the next time though I'm
a ho oh ho start dressing like a hike
Beast we're supreme shirts and sipping
and walk around a nice sneakers and
dance danced around as soon as someone
brings up politics I don't give you 45
dress like a 15 year old let Siri just
when I'm on it a good Siri
Jessica 15 year old somebody's let's
bring up politics just to go Chum dosier
girl have you seen this mu and then just
start saying it to dinner go [ __ ] imma
cow [ __ ] imma cow I'm not a cat I don't
say meow and when they go you're insane
go no you're insane you're insane
talking about bado O'Rourke Timbaland
comedy calm for all the live dates see
you later